[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها بالعناوين
هذا الاتفاق سيكون بسيط امل لاهل السودان
بالذات اهل الخرطوم قبل دخول اتفاقه وقف
اطلاق النار حيز التنفيذ الجيش السوداني
يقول ان الهدنه لا تتضمن المسائل السياسيه
نحو الفضاء ساعات تفصل عن القرن وريان
برناوي عن الانطلاق للمحطه الدوليه
وبالتزامن مع الرحله التاريخيه معارض في
مدن سعوديه للتعريف بالمهمه العلميه
لرائدى
رابعه ايضا
اطلاق مسمى الرواق السعوديه على التوسعه
الجديده للمطاف في المسجد الحرام
اصول اول رحلات الحجاج لهذا العام الى جده
والمدينه
2700 حاج من عده دول
اعلنت السعوديه والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في بيان مشترك ان طرفي الصراع
في السودان الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع وقع على اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار
لمده سبعه ايام وجاء في البيان المشترك ان
وقف اطلاق النار سيدخل حيز التنفيذ بعد 48
ساعه من التوقيع ويمكن تمديده بموافقه
الطرفين واضاف البيان ان الجانبين اتفقا
على ايصال وتوزيع المساعدات الانسانيه
واستعاده الخدمات الاساسيه بالاضافه الى
سحب القوات من المستشفيات والمرافق العامه
الاساسيه
لا يخفى عليكم
حرص المملكه العربيه السعوديه وخادم
الحرمين والعهد على السودان وعلى استقرار
السودان وعلى امن السودان
ونسال الله ان شاء الله ان يرفع هذه الغمه
على السودان وعن اهلها ان شاء الله
والحقيقه شاكرين على موقفكم هذا اليوم
وعلى تعاونكم في الوصول الى هذا الاتفاق
واهل السودان منتظرين هذا وهذا ان شاء
الله في خير كثير يعني تعرفون انه الدم
هذا غالي والدم السوداني غالي وانتم
تاخذونه اكثر يعني اكثر من اي احد ان شاء
الله هذا الاتفاق سيكون بصيص امل لاهل
السودان بالذات اهل الخرطوم في انه يعني
يستطيعون ان يعالجون امورهم الانسانيه في
هذه الايام وان شاء الله تلتد الى اكثر
وان شاء الله تكون خطوه في الطريق الصحيح
فبارك الله فيكم وشكرا لكم على تجاوبكم
وشكرا على موقفكم هذا وان شاء الله يعني
ما نرى من بعد هذا الا كل الخير للسودان
واهل السودان ان شاء الله
وتعقيبا على الهدنه قال الجيش السوداني ان
اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار مع الدعم السريع
ينحصر على الجوانب العسكريه ولا يتضمن
المسائل السياسيه ودعا الجيش السوداني في
بيان قوات الدعم السريع الى الالتزام
بالهدنه التي تم التوافق عليها في جده
لتسهيل ايصال وتوزيع المساعدات الانسانيه
واستعاده الخدمات وسحب القوات من
المستشفيات والمرافق العامه الاساسيه
وتسهيل المرور الامن لمقدمه المساعدات
الانسانيه والسلعه
قال وزير الخارج جهه الامريكيه في تغريده
له عبر تويتر من الوقت قد حان لاسكات
المدافع والسماح بوصول المساعدات
الانسانيه من دون عوائق واضاف بلنكن قائلا
اناشد كلا الجانبين التمسك بهذا الاتفاق
فانظار العالم تركب
يوم تاريخي انتظره السعوديون لعقود يبدا
فيه رائداء الفضاء على القرني وريان
برناوي الرحله الى المحطه الدوليه في رحله
علميه تمثل حدثا تاريخيا للسعوديه وتدشن
مرحله جديده لها في مجال الفضه حيث كشفت
الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء عن اكتمال
الاستعدادات النهائيه لرائدي الفضاء
السعوديين واوضحت الهيئه ان صاروخ فالكون
9 ومركبه دراغون على منصه الاطلاق
استعدادا لنقل طاقم مهمه
التي تضمر ايدي الفضاء السعوديين الى محطه
الفضاء الدوليه مبينه ان هذه الرحله تاتي
ضمن برنامج السعوديه لرواد الفضاء الذي تم
اطلاقه في سبتمبر 2022
وبالتزامن مع الرحله المنتظره لرواد
الفضاء السعوديين تشهد ثلاث مدن اقامه
معارض السعوديه نحو الفضاء بالتزامن مع
انطلاق المهمه العلميه لرواد الفضاء
السعوديين في محطه الفضاء الدوليه تقام
المعارض في مدن الرياض وجده والظهران خلال
الفتره من الحادي والعشرين من مايو الجري
حتى الاول من يونيو المقبل وتهدف الى
تقديم فرص فريده لاستكشاف قطاع الفضاء
والتعرف على الرحلات الفضائيه وتاريخها
ورفع مستوى الاهتمام بالفضاء وعلومه
وتخصصاته العلميه والتقنيه لدى الاجيال
الناشئه
من الرياض ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
نصفيان ومن فلوريدا العربيه حسين الطود
مرحبا بكم ابدا معك هاني حول معرض نحو
الفضاء في الرياض ما هي ابرز معالم هذا
المعرض
نعم يا خالد اهلا بك واهلا بمشاهدي قناه
العربيه طبعا معرض نحو الفضاء والذي تم
انشاءه من قبل الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء في
يوم يتزامن مع اطلاق الصاروخ انطلاق رائدي
الفضاء الى المحطه وكاله الفضاء الدوليه
طبعا هذا المعرض يضم القطع التي يستخدمها
رائدي الفضاء وكذلك القطع ايضا التي سوف
يتجه اليها رائدي الفضاء وايضا بعض
المعلومات عن
انطلاق رحله رائدي الفضاء حتى وصولهما
وايضا عودتهما ان شاء الله سالمين عموما
هذا المرض سوف يحكي الينا فيه وبيتفاصيله
المستشار في هيئه الفضاء السعوديه الدكتور
هيثم التويج مرحبا بك دكتور يعني نشاهد
قطع ومعلومات عن
عن القطع التي سوف يستخدمها الرائديه
الفضاء
هي يعني قطع لاول مره نشاهدها في هذا
المرض في وقت يتزامن وجود ثلاث معارض في
ثلاث مناطق سعوديه سلمك الله اول قطعه
نتكلم عنها اللي هي نموذج المركبه
اللي راح يستخدمها رائد الفضاء للوصول الى
محطه الفضاء الدوليه وهي عباره عن قطعتين
القطعه العلويه اللي هي الكبسوله وين يكون
فيه رواد الفضاء والقطعه السفليه هذا
يعني على الهيد هو راح يكون التواجد راي
الفضاء بمقعد داخلي مقعد داخلي الاربعه
اربع رواد فقط هي في اربع مقاعد في
مساعده كوماندر وفي مقعد للاخصائيين ريانه
ويا علي ان شاء الله
ايضا هناك الزي الخاص فيهم يعني يشاهد
الزي اللي راح يرتديه الفضاء ريانه وعلي
طبعا البدله هذه بدله فضائيه هذه تعتبر
البدله اللي يستخدمونها رواد الفضاء في
تواجدهم في
المركبه الفضائيه وكذلك لما يتواجدون على
محطه الفضاء الدوليه بينما هذه غير مؤهله
انها يسمحون فيها في الفضاء انما هذه
تعتبر احدى البدله التي يتم استخدامها
يعني هناك عده بدلات يعني يستخدمها على
حسب يعني هل رائد الفضاء راح ياخذ تجربه
السباحه في الفضاء او الخروجه اللي يسمونه
او فقط راح يكون متواجدين في محطه الفضاء
وروادنا ان شاء الله راح يكونون متواجدين
في محطه الفضاء دكتور يعني نشوف هنا روبوت
مختلف هل هذا الروبوت سوف يتم استخدامه من
ري انه او علي لا هذا سلم نموذج عن
روبر موجوده الان على سطح المريخ
واحد من اثنين
كوريوس
في الواقع الحجم هذا لا يمثل حجمها
الحقيقي نعم
طيب عندنا مجموعه من الصواريخ طبعا برضو
اشكال من الصواريخ دائما نتحدث واحد تلو
الاخر اذا تعطينا معلومات عن هذه الصواريخ
هل هذا الصاروخ الذي سوف يصعد عليه ريانه
علي لا هذا بالنسبه للنموذج اللي امامنا
هذا
الصاروخت هذا اللي يستخدم في الستينات وفي
الاضاءه للسبعينات للذهاب للقمر نعم طيب
ماذا عن الصاروخ الثاني في الجانب هذا
الصاروخ الاخر هذا النموذج اخر صاروخ
قاعده تجهز وكانت الفضاء الامريكيه ناقصه
ويعتبر يسمى
اللي هو
الجديد اللي راح يستخدم كذلك في مهمات
الذهاب للقمر وبرنامج ارتمس اذا هذا
الصاروخ لراي اليه فضاء ريان وعلي نعم هذا
نعم هذا الفاكن هذا من شركه سبيس اكس وزي
ما تشوف عباره عن قطعتين القطعه الاولى
هذه تعود للارض وبعدين القطعه العلويه هذه
اللي يكون فيها الكبسوله والرواد الفضاء
شكرا لك دكتور هيثم اذا هذه المعلومات
التي اوضحها الدكتور هيثم التويجري وهو
مستشار هيئه الفضاء السعودي والذي اوضح
لانواع الصواريخ والمجسمات وكذلك البدء
التي سوف يرتديها ريانه وعلي وكذلك القطعه
التي سوف يصعد عليها ريانه وعلي اثناء
انطلاقهم مساء هذا اليوم في تمام الساعه
العاشره ونصف مساء بتوقيت المحلي السعودي
اذهب الى فلوريدا الى مفرد العربيه حسين
الطودة حسين مرحبا بك بانتظار ساعه
الانطلاق هذا اليوم ما الذي يحدث الان هل
انتهت كل الاستعدادات
تحيه لك خالد وهاني نحن الان بالقرب من
مركز كندي للفضاء ننتظر دخولنا الى المركز
بعد نحو ساعه تقريبا بالنسبه لرايدي
الفضاء ريان وعلي لقد اكمل الاستعدادات
النهائيه البارحه اليوم بعد حوالي تقريبا
ثلاث ساعات على الساعه الثانيه عشره
والنصف بتوقيت فلوريدا سيصيل الفريق
الفريق مهمه اي اكس اثنان ومعهم ريانه
وعلياء عبر مروحيه الى مركز كندي حيث
سيخرجا من المروحيه ويلوحان لاهاليهم
ولاصدقائهم وعلى الساعه الواحده والربع
تقريبا سيستلم فريق سبيس اكس هذا الفريق
فريق رواد الفضاء لاجراء التحضيرات
النهائيه عمليه الاطلاق ستكون طبعا على
الساعه الخامسه ونصف بالتوقيت المحلي
بالنسبه للصاروخ كما شرح وتفضل الزملاء
الرياض هو يتكون من جزئين الجزء الاول هو
الكبسوله دراغون والجزء الثاني هو صاروخ
فالكون بالنسبه لدراجون هي اول مركبه
فضائيه خاصه لنقل البشر الى المحطه
الفضائيه وبالنسبه للجزء الثاني فهيكون من
قسمين او بطبيعه الحال القسم الاول هو
القسم الاكبر ويتضمن تسعه محركات كبيره
والقسم الثاني يتكون من محرك واحد عندما
ينطلق هذا الصاروخ سينفصل عندما يصل الى
عشره اضعاف سرعه الصوت تقريبا على ارتفاع
80 كيلو متر سينتصل الجزء الاول ثم يبدا
القسم الثاني بالمحرك القسم الثاني بالعمل
حتى يضع المركبه في مدار معين فوق الارض
قبل ان ينفصل هو بعد ذلك بعد نحو ثمانيه
دقائق لتسبح هذه المركبه وتاخذ عمليه
الالتحام
المحطه الدوليه نحو تقريبا 16 ساعه حتى
تخفف السرعه طبعا الرواد الجريان كما قلنا
الاستعدادات انهوها البارحه هناك عندما
يصلون الى المحطه الدوليه سيجري الفريق
السعودي 14 تجربه علميه تتعلق بالجاذبيه
وتاثيرها الجاذبيه على الاعضاء البشريه
وتجارب علميه اخرى
بعد ذلك حسب ما فهمنا سيبقون هناك نحو
اسبوع قبل رحله العوده الى الارض
هنا حسب ما لاحظنا في وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه هناك تغطيه لهذا الموضوع هناك
اهتمام كون ريانه هي اول رائده فضاء عربيه
وسعوديه تذهب الى الفضاء وتلتحق بالمحطه
الدولي الدوليه هذا له اهميه ينظر اليه
هنا على هذا الامر
كما قلنا ما زلنا ننتظر الدخول الى
مركز سندي حيث سنكون اقرب من الصاروخ
ويمكننا الحصول على صور اكثر دقه من هو
عليه الان ونحن بالتاكيد سنتابع معك كل
التفاصيل لاحقه ايضا في نشراته واثناء
تغطيه العربيه ايضا لخدل الحدث التاريخي
المهم شكرا لك من فلوريدا في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه نصفيان من الرياض
طريق صعب وشاق ينتظر رائدي الفضاء
السعوديين علي وريان بعد ساعات من الان
الزميل نايف الاحمري يعطينا عرضا افتراضيا
عن الرحله كيف ستبدا ومتى ستنتهي وبتقنيه
الواقع المعزز
هذا ليس صاروخا يستخدم في حروب العصر
الحديث انه فالكون تسعه ذلك الصاروخ الذي
ينقلنا الى ابعد رحلات استكشافيه في الكون
وربما في اهم رحلات التنقيب عن اسرار
الفضاء وحل الغازه هذا الصاروخ مشاهدينا
تلتصق فيه مركبه دراغون التي نراها هنا في
الجزء الاول من الصاروخ سيكون على متر
دراغون اول امراه سعوديه تحلق نحو الفضاء
ريان برناوي وعلي القرني رائد الفضاء
السعودي يقومان برحله الى الفضاء الخارجي
لزياره محطه الفضاء الدوليه رفقه اثنين
اخرين ايضا ضمن مهمتي
اول رحله صعود الى الفضاء لفريق رواد
سعوديين لتدشن المملكه عصرا جديدا في
استكشاف الفضاء وعلامه فارقه
في الحدث التاريخي تعالوا معنا مشاهدينا
لنصعد الى الفضاء افتراضيا طبعا لكن حذاري
انها ليست كاي رحله الوصول الى الفضاء
وحده يستغرق نحو 24 ساعه وقبل التحليق
لابد لرواد الفضاء المرور بمراحل عده
وتدريبات مكثفه واختبارات حاسمه وهذا ما
مر به علي وريانا بالطبع حيث خضع لكافه
البرامج التدريبيه التي تساعدهم على اتمام
هذه المهمه بنجاح واجراء التجارب العلميه
المتعلقه برحلتهم الى الفضاء
تبدا الرحله فعليا مشاهدينا بالصعود على
متن مركبه دراجون اول مركبه فضائيه تنقل
البشر الى المحطه الفضائيه تصل حموله
المركبه الى اربعه ركاب من والى المدار
نشاهدهم هنا في استديو العربيه لكنها
قادره ايضا على اعاده كميات كبيره من
الحمولات الى الارض لنستعد ايضا لمرحله
الاطلاق بعد انطلاقه من المنصه يصل
الصاروخ لسرعه الصوت لا ننسى ان هذا
الصاروخ مشاهدينا يمر باعلى منطقه ضغط
هوائي ديناميكي
وبارتفاع 80 كيلو مترا تتم عمليه الانفصال
الاول بعد 70 دقائق وحين يصل لمدار الارض
المنخفض يتم الانفصال الثاني ومن ثم ترتبط
محطه دراغون بمحطه الفضاء
الدوليه هذه هي المحطه في هذه المرحله
يقوم الطاقم في مركبه دراغون بعمل مناوره
باستخدام الدافعات كما نشاهد الان حتى يتم
الاقتراب والتصاق دراغون بمحطه الفضاء
الدوليه اذا قد وصلنا مشاهدينا الى المحطه
في هذه الرحله التي سيجري فيها رواد
الفضاء السعوديين اربع عشره تجربه رائده
في الجاذبيه الصغرى بما فيها تجارب توعويه
تعليميه يشارك فيها 12 الف طالب وطالب
واثنين واربعين موقعا في السعوديه عبر
الاقمار الصناعيه مهمات كثيره ولا فتنه
مشاهدين بانتظار علي وريان في الفضاء ونحن
هنا على الارض ننتظر عودتهم من الفضاء
سالمين
ونتوقف الان مع هذه المقابله الخاصه التي
اجراها الزميل حسن الطالعي مع رائد الفضاء
ريان وعلي يشرحاني فيها الرحله نحو الفضاء
والمراحل التي مر بها قبل الانطلاقه اليوم
ان شاء الله
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام في مقابله خاصه
يسرني ان استضيف رايدي الفضاء السعوديين
ريان برناوي وعلي القرني اهلا بكم اهلا
بكم شكرا
للحديث عن هذه المهمه التاريخيه يعطيكم
العافيه طبعا بالتاكيد نقاط كثيره راح
نتكلم عنها لكن خلوني ابدا من حيث
انتهيتما هنا في السعوديه قبل المغادره
التقيتم بولي العهد السعودي
بالتاكيد اللقاء كان مهم بالنسبه لكم قبل
المغادره ريان ابدا معاكي
كيف شفتي اللقاء لماذا خرجت من هذا اللقاء
مساء الخير استاذ حسن ومساء الخير على
جميع المشاهدين
يعني رحلتنا هذه المره كانت مختلفه نحن
جينا على استقبال ولي العهد لنا ففي
البدايه اود ان اتقدم بجزيل الشكر
والعرفان لولي العهد
ورئيس مجلس رئيس المجلس الاعلى للفضاء
لاستقباله لنا الحمد لله كلمات مو كانت
كانها دافع لنا يعني تحمسنا وتزيدنا تفاؤل
ان احنا ننفذ هذه المهمه باذن الله على
اكمل وجه وفي نفس الوقت كان ياكد لنا دعمه
واهتمامه ولا محدود بمجال الفضاء وانه هو
دائما معانا في كل خطوه وانه باذن الله
هذا احدى مشاريع الرؤيه
فهدفنا باذن الله في هذه المرحله هو تعزيز
مكانه المملكه عالميا في مجال استكشاف
الفضاء خصوصا في خدمه البشريه فباذن الله
الان انا وعلي
اخواننا رواد الفضاء الاخرين نحس
بجاهزيتنا نحس انه نحن الان جاهزين نحط
بصمه المملكه في مجال الفضاء وانه حين
المملكه لازم تكون في خارطه الدول اللي
تتنافس وتستثمر في مجال الفضاء فالحمد لله
كان استقباله لنا اجمل دافع واجمل دعم لنا
الحمد لله عليه اتشرفنا صراحه بلقاء سمو
الامير محمد بن سلمان ولي العهد حفظه الله
قائد النهضه اللي نعيش فيها حاليا كلمات
التحفيزيه شجعنا وايدنا ان نروح ونواصل
رؤيه المملكه واهتمامها باستكشاف الفضاء
واتاحه الفضاء لمشاركه العلماء السعوديين
بمشاركه تجاربهم ان شاء الله في امه محطه
الفضاء الدوليه ريان اعود لك ربما من ابرز
الاسئله او كمدخل ايضا
لحظات الاولى تلقيتي فيها خبر اختيارك
كرائده فضاء سعوديه
نعيش معك هذا الجو وكيف كانت رده الفعل
بالنسبه لك والله استاذ حسن كان بالنسبه
لي يوم استثنائي في حياتي يعني يوم ما
تلقيت الخبر انا الى الان اعجز اني الاقي
كلمات توصف شعوري هذاك الوقت حماس تفاؤل
فخر اعتزاز يعني
بحاجه احسها تفوق الوصف يعني
احس كاني اتذكر موقف كانه صار امس يعني
كنت مستعده لابسه الباطل البلطه حق
المختبر حقي وخلاص طالعه من البيت رايحه
على دوامي
وصلني اتصال يعني فرديت طلع الاتصال من
الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء
فاول ما كلموني قالوا لي ريانه انت الان
صرتي اقرب للحلم مبروك تم اختيارك كاول
رائده فضاء السعوديه تذهب لمحطه الفضاء
الدوليه يعني الجمله لحالها خلاص يعني صرت
ماني عارفه دحين اروح الدوام ولا اخذ
اجازه لان الان رائده فضاء او باحثه ما
صرت عارفه يعني كيف اتصرف انا بحكم عملي
في مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي انا اسكن في
الرياض واهلي في جده في احد الاشخاص اللي
مهمين بالنسبه لي هي ستي ام الوالده كنت
حابه اني انا اقول لها الخبر وهي بجده
فطلعت على الغرفه جلست على السرير اتصلت
على العمل وطلبت يوم اجازه واخذت تذكره من
الرياض لجده بس عشان ابلغها الخبر العظيم
رده الفعل بالتاكيد كانت كبيره جدا كانت
لا توصف علي
اكيد خضعته لتدريبات كثيره في لانجاز هذه
المهمه ابرز الاشياء اللي خضعته لها حتى
يتم تاهيلكم بشكل كامل طبعا ولله الحمد
اتمنى مؤخرا اجمال التدريبات المتعلقه
بالرحله وكانت بشكل عام التدريب على
المهام اليوميه التشغيليه لمحطه الفضاء
الدوليه تدربنا على مركزين الابحاث
الاوروبي والياباني كذلك
التدريبات وجمله على كيفيه التعايش داخل
المحطه الفضاء الدوليه وكذلك محاكاه
للانطلاق والعوده التدرب على الادوات اللي
بنستخدمها ان شاء الله في الابحاث العلميه
والابحاث
العمليه ان شاء الله على متن المحطه
فهذه التدريبات بشكل عام تثبت او او
تمكننا من القدره على النجاح في هذه
المهمه وكذلك بعد المهمه ان شاء الله نعود
الى ارض الوطن محققين جميع الاهداف
المرجوه من هذه الرحله بالتاكيد هناك عديد
من التجارب
والمهام اللي راح تؤد في الفضاء لو ندخل
في بعض تفاصيل هذه التجارب بالنسبه لكم
مهمتنا بالاساس هي مهمه علميه فباذن الله
سنقوم باجراء 14 تجربه علميه بحثيه رائده
يعني لاول مره في التاريخ باذن الله هذه
التجارب تعنى بمجالات متعدده اولها هي
ثلاث تجارب توعويه تعليميه ستكون
لها علاقه بالتعاون مع الطلاب فهذه
التجارب كلها هدفها تحفيز الطلاب وتحفيز
الفضول لديهم في مجال الفضاء وباذن الله
سنقوم باجراء اربع تجارب علميه لها علاقه
بالخلايا المناعيه وهذه باذن الله حتكون
اول مره في التاريخ سنقوم بزراعه خلايا
مناعيه في بيئه الجاذبيه الصغرى بحيث انه
نزرع الخلايا ونضيف علاجات مختلفه عليها
ونشوف مدى استجابتها في بيئه الجاذبيه
الصوره البحث لاول مره يجرى في التاريخ
بدعم سمو سيدي حفظه الله احب اضيف على
كلام زميلتي ريان انه سوف نقوم باجراء سته
تجارب في الطب البشري وهذا التجارب تعنى
بدراسه التغيرات على التي قد تصيب الدماغ
الجهاز العصبي العظام وكذلك النظر هذه
الدراسات سبق وتم اجرائها في بيئه
الجاذبيه الصغرى ولكن الجديد انه سوف يتم
استخدام اجهزه جديده لاول مره في الفضاء
بشانها المساعده في تسريع النتائج
والتحاليل ان شاء الله وكذلك في الاستمطار
الصناعي وهذه تجربه فيزيائيه تعتبر كاول
مره تحدث كذلك في الفضاء وهي من شانها او
كفيله نتائج هذه التجربه بزياده ورفع
كفاءه الاستمطار الصناعي في الارض من 15%
الى اكثر من 50% ان شاء الله وسوف تساعدنا
باذن الله في الاسهام على مكافحه التصحر
ومشاريع السعوديه لرؤيه 2030 مثل الرياض
الخضراء والشرق الاوسط الاخضر باذن الله
ريان بصفتك اول رائده فضاء سعوديه ممكن
الرساله اللي ممكن تقدميها للمواطنات
السعوديات بعد هذه التجربه بالتاكيد اللي
يمكن الكثير ما كان متوقع انه ممكن يتم
انجازها خلال هذه الفتره القصيره صحيح هي
فعلا تجربه كبيره يعني شخصيا انا احس
بالفخر ولكن كميه مسؤوليه عاليه كوني اول
رائده فضاء سعوديه لكن هذا الشيء ايش
يورينا يورينا ثقه قيادتنا الرشيده فانه
المراه السعوديه تقدر تعمل في جميع
المجالات وايمانهم ان هم لهم دور جدا كبير
في تنميه الوطن وبناء الوطن باذن الله
بالعكس انصح الجميع باستغلال جميع الفرص
المتاحه لجميع السعوديات باذن الله لانه
كل الاحلام الان مدعومه كل شيء متوفر نحن
في عصر التمكين وعصر الازدهار دورنا فقط
نرفع شان المملكه عاليا باذن الله ايضا
على القرني بالتاكيد بالنسبه لك انت ايضا
هذه الرحله
امر كبير جدا وبالتالي كل ما يمكن انجازه
خلال هذه الرحله
يعتبر بالنسبه لك شيء عظيم رسالتك للشباب
السعودي مع هذه الرحله منذ البدايه وحتى
النهايه ان شاء الله انا كشاب سعودي وتيحت
لهذه الفرصه احب ان اوجه رساله لاخواني
واخواتي السعوديين احنا نعيش حاليا وقت
حاسم في المملكه العربيه السعوديه وبنقوم
بمهمه تاريخيه للمملكه بالذهاب الى محطه
الفضاء الدوليه كاول سعوديين على متنها
وهذه مهمه تمثل خطوه كبيره جدا في اطار
بناء جيل جديد من القاده والمستكشفين
والعلماء والباحثين ويجب علينا ان نكون
مصدر الهام الاجيال في الوطن العربي الى
افاق جديده تساعد البشريه على الاستفاده
من التجارب في الفضاء وكذلك يجب على كل
شاب وشابه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
حاليا ان يكون عنده حسن ظن قيادتنا
وتطلعاتهم فينا وانه يجب علينا ان نحمل
ونضع المملكه العربيه السعوديه على خارطه
الدول المتقدمه باظهار مدى تقدمنا
بالتكنولوجيا والابحاث والعلوم ان شاء
الله كل التوفيق اتمنى لكم ان شاء الله
خلال هذه المهمه انتم ايضا وطاقم العمل
ربما ان شاء الله نلتقيكم بعد عودتكم الى
ارض الوطن سالمين باذن الله شكرا لكم انتم
ايضا مشاهدينا الكرام الى اللقاء
رابع مستمره فيها بعد قليل
طلقه مسمى الرواق السعودي على التوسعه
الجديده للمطاف في المسجد الحرام
قبل دخول اتفاق وقفي اطلاق النار حيز
التنفيذ الجيش السوداني يقول ان الهدنه لا
تتضمن المسائل السياسيه
السعوديه نحو الفضاء ساعات تفصل عن القرن
وريان برناوي عن الانطلاق للمحطه الدوليه
وبالتزامن مع رحله التاريخيه معارض في مدن
سعوديه للتعريف بالمهمه العلميه لرائدي
الفضاء
اطلاق مسمى رواق السعوديه على التوسعه
الجديده للمطاف في المسجد الحرام
واصول الى رحلات الحجاج لهذا العامله جده
والمدينه
2700 حج من عده دول
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت دراسه العامه
لشؤون الحرمين عن صدور موافقه ملكيه
باطلاق تسميه الرواق السعودي على مبنى
مشروع توسعه المطاف في المسجد الحرم وبين
رئيس الرئاسه العامه لشؤون الحرمين
الدكتور عبد الرحمن السديس ان الرواقه
السعوديه يتضمن مشروع توسعه المطاف خلف
الرواق العباسي ويتكون من اربعه ادوار
بطاقه استيعابيه تصل الى 287 الف مصلل في
الساعه وفق معايير هندسيه عاليه
المناسبه العظيمه واسمي باسم قاصد الحرمين
الشريفين والطائفين والقائمين والركع
السجود لنرفع اسمى ايات الشكر والامتنان
والتقدير والعرفان للمقام الكريم على هذه
المكرمه التاريخيه الفريده ويحق لكل مسلم
ولك يهودي ان يرفع بذلك راسا ويبتهج نفسا
وينشرح صدرا ويقر عينا بهذا الانجاز
الاستثنائي المبهر كما نرفع التهنئه مضمخه
مضوعه بالدعاء والولاء لاولاه امرنا
الميامين ثناء عاطرا ودعاء وافرا على هذه
الجهود المباركه
من مكه المكرمه ينضم الينا الدكتور عبد
الله الشريف استاذ كرسي الملك سلمان بن
عبد العزيز للدراسات التاريخ مكه المكرمه
في جامعه ام الكره حياك الله دكتور عبد
الله معي في نشره الرابعه اولا مسياق
التاريخي
للرواق السعودي وما هي مراحل العمل على
هذا الرواق حتى
شكرا للاستضافه الكريمه والحقيقه انه
اطلاق مسمى الرواق السعودي على
العماره السعوديه وعلى الرواق السعودي
المحيط بالرواق العباسي في المسجد الحرام
امرا يدل الحقيقه على اهتمام خادم الحرمين
الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز حفظه
الله ولي عهد الامين حفظه الله بالحرمين
الشريفين حقيقه ايضا يعد انعكاسا
للرعايه الحكوميه للدوله السعوديه
المباركه
بالمسجد الحرامي منذ عهد المؤسس الملك عبد
العزيز بن عبد الرحمن ال سعود لا شك اخي
الاستاذ خالد
والمشاهدين الكرام بان من المعلوم ان
العماره عماره المسجد الحرام ظلت قرون
عديده تصل الى نحو 1200 عام على الع
العباسيه او ما عرفت الرواقه العباسي وذلك
انه من المعلوم ان الخليفه محمد المهدي بن
ابي جعفر بن المنصور العباسي قد بنى
الرواق العباسي للمحيط للمطاف والكعبه
المشرفه في فتره خلافته ما بين 158 الى
169 وقد زار مكه المكرمه مرتين سنه
160 وسنه
وقرر يعني عماره المسجد وتوسيعته وفعلا في
العام الاول حمل اموالا عظيمه واشرف على
امر بدايه التنفيذ ولكنه حين جاء مكه في
سنه 64 وجد ان الكعبه لا تتوسط المسجد
الحرام فامر بتوسعه المسجد الحرام من
الناحيه الجنوبيه بما هو محاذاه جبل الصفا
وحول مجرى المسيل الى ما يلصق الجبل بعد
هدم تلك البيوت هذه العماره العباسيه التي
ايضا حصل لها زيادتين في عهد المقتدر
والمعتضد العباسي اصبحت هي العماره
الاسلاميه للمسجد الحرام وظل الرواق
العباسي هو الرواق الامثل والباقي حتى
قيام الدوله السعوديه لنحو 1200 عام
[موسيقى]
عدا ما كان من اصلاحات او ترميمات
تمت على يد الدول الاسلاميه المتعاقبه بعد
الدوله العباسيه وصولا الى الدوله
السعوديه المباركه ما هو التقرير ما هو
الرواق العباسي بس لو في تفاصيل عنه دكتور
عبد الله الرواق العباسي هو البناء المحيط
بالمطافي وبالكعبه المشرفه والرواق هو ما
كان بين صفين من الاعمده ما بين صفين من
الاعمده وقد بني في العهد العباسي على
اعمده عده بنحو 496 عمودا
سخرت لها السفن من البحر الاحمر ومن
الخليج العربي وصولا الى ميناء الشعيبه ثم
الى المسجد الحرام وسقف بخشب الساجي
طبقتين
استخدمت من بلاد الهند وزينت وزخرفت ولنت
وكان هذا من باب يعني حج اشعه الشمس عن
المصلين وايضا لتدوم فتره طويله وقيله انه
استخدم فيها عماره متينه ومبتكره حتى
استطاعت الصمود هذا الوقت الطويل الذي قدر
بنحو 1200
عام
فالرواق كلما كان بين صفين من الاعمده
ويكون مسامت ومحاذي لجدار القبله في
المسجد الحرم
البناء السعودي او ما يسمى الان الرواقه
السعودي الذي اطلق هذا المصطلح اليوم هو
الحقيقه يعني عماره سعوديه عظيمه مرت بث
مراحل اساسيه
فالمؤسس العظيم الملك عبد العزيز بن عبد
الرحمن ال سعود رحمه الله منذ ان دخل مكه
واستظلت بظل دولته المباركه عمل على
الاهتمام بالمسجد الحرام ورممه وصانه
وحسنه وكذلك المسعى وظلله وكثير من
الاعمال التي قام بها الا انه توج تلك
الاعمال
بالرغبه في بناء رواق سعودي يحيط بالرواق
العباسي ويوسع على المسلمين ويستوعب هذه
الاعداد الكبيره وتم هذا البناء في عهد
الملك سعود بن عبد العزيز رحمه الله واطلق
سنه
1375 واستمر في عهد الفيصل وفي عهد الملك
خالد رحمه الله جميعا وكان هذا ما يسمى
بالتوسعه السعوديه الاولى الا ان هذه
التوسعه الحقيقه لم تكن توسعه فقط بل كانت
عباره اسلاميه عظيمه
اليوم دكتور عبد الله واعذرني على مقاطاه
ما الذي يتميز به الرواق السعودي في توسعه
الجديده
والى اي مدى هناك يعني محافظه او اهتمام
بالمحافظه على الهويه التاريخيه في في كل
المراحل اللي مرت وخصوصا اليوم ربما
اولا يعني اخذ في الاعتبار في
العماره السعوديه ان التصاميم هذه العماره
تكون تصاميم اسلاميه
متميزه وراقيه فذات روح اسلامي كما حافظت
على بعض العناصر العناصر الاساسيه في
المسجد الحرام وان تبقى قائمه ومشهوده كما
حافظت على بعض النقوش وعلى الاعمده بعض
الاعمده القديمه القادره على الاستمرار
ولكن هذه العماره عملت على مستوى في
العماره السعوديه الاولى على ثلاثه ادوار
القبو والدور الارضي والدور الاول وكذلك
المسع وهذا يعني نقله معماريه كبيره جدا
في المسجد الحرام توسعه السعوديه الثانيه
الملك فهد الله يرحمه اضاف الى المسجد
السعوديه التاليه وهي مكان السوق الصغير
او ما يسمى بسوق الحجره قديما وهي ايضا
توسعه يعني استغربت فيها احدث الاساليب
المعماريه ثم في عهد الملك عبد الله بن
عبد العزيز رحمه الله امر بالتوسعه
السعودي الثالثه في الناحيه الشماليه
للمسجد الحرام
وحينما تولى خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز تفضل
وجهها وجهها باستثمالها ودشن المرحله
الاولى منها وبفضل الله ومنته هي الان
تستكمل وهي في مراحلها الاخيره
وقد اضافت الى المسجد الحرام بعدا عظيما
من حيث الحقيقه ان التوسعه السعودي ايضا
امتازت بجمال التصميم ممتازت باستخدام
افضل
المواد وهذا تم في جميع التوسعات السعوديه
ثلاث التصاميم المميزه وايضا استخدام افضل
المواد المتاحه معماريا وايضا الزخارف
والثريات الراقيه واستخدام الرخام في الا
والرخام المقاومه لحراره الشمس واصبح
المسجد الحرام يستوعب الان نحو مليونين
مصمم في ان واحد واصبح المطاف يستوعب نحو
107 107 الف طائف في الساعه وبهذا اصبح
الرواق السعودي يمثل عماره اسلاميه تعد
ايقونها عالميه لقد اصبح المسجد الحرام من
اعظم المباني واكبرها مساحه واكثرها
استيعابا على مستوى العالم وليس على مستوى
الوطني في المملكه العربيه السعوديه شكرا
لك الدكتور عبد الله بن حسين الشريف استاذ
كرسي الملك سلمان لدراسات تاريخ مكه
المكرمه في جامعه ام القرى شكرا لك دكتور
يعطيك العافيه شكرا
[موسيقى]
لكم
وصلت الى المدينه المنوره وجده اولى رحلات
الحجاج هذا العام وعلى متنها اكثر من 2500
حج ياتي ذلك في ظل استعدادات تنظيميه
وتشغيليه تعمل عليها السعوديه من خلال
مختلف الجهات الحكوميه استعدادا لاستقبال
اكثر من مليون ونصف المليون حاج هذا العام
وتعمل وزاره الداخليه السعوديه على تنفيذ
مبادره الطريق مكه للعام الخامس من دول
المغرب واندونيسيا وماليزيا باكستان
وغيرها من الدول
في الرابع بعد قليل بعد اربعه اشهر من
عمليه الفصل الرابع تواكب الحاله الصحيه
للسيامي العراقي علي وعمر
اهلا بكم من جديد الفيضانات السنويه هاجس
يتكرر في الصومال مدى رابطه العالم
الاسلامي لانشاء مشروعي قنوات ايضا قبل
عام من الان الذي ساهم في الحد من اضرار
تلك الفيضانات
في قلب الصومال مدينه بلدوين الواقعه على
ضفاف نهر شبيله مدينه يقطنها اكثر من
مليون نسمه هم على موعد سنوي مع زائر ثقيل
يشرد مئات الالاف منهم ويدمر بناهم
التحتيه ويخلف مئات الضحايا في كل عام
الفيضانات كارثه طبيعيه متعلقه بالمناخ
الا انها باتت في السنوات الاخيره احد
ابرز ما يهدد حياه سكان هذه المدينه لكن
في مايو الحال تعرضت مناطق من اقليم هيران
وتحديدا مدينه بلدوين لفيضانات لم تشهدها
منذ 80 عاما فكان لمشروع قنوات بلد وين
الذي عملت عليه رابطه العالم الاسلامي
كمشروع مستدام بشراكه مع جهات حكوميه
محليه كان له دور بارز في الحد من مخاطر
الفيضانات الاخيره حيث هدفت الرابطه من
خلال المشروع الى توفير اكثر من 300 الف
متر مكعب من المياه وري واستصلاح الاراضي
الزراعيه على جانبي القنوات اضافه الى
تغذيه المياه الجوفيه وذلك عبر تشييد
اربعه جسور رئيسيه تمثل خزانا مائيا ضخما
وتنفيذ السته جسور على القناتين وشق
القنوات الشرقيه واعاده تاهيل القناه
الغربيه بطول 13 كيلومترا
المشروع تبنته الرابطه بعد كارثه حلت
بالمدينه في العام 2018 حيث تسببت
الفيضانات بتشريد اكثر من 700 الف نسمه
الى خارج المدينه فضلا عما صاحبتها من
اضرار كبيره وسلمته الرابطه للحكومه
المحليه في العام 2022 وهو ما اسهم بشكل
كبير في تقليل اضرار الفيضانات غير
المسبوقه
بعد مرور اكثر من اربعه اشهر منذ اجراء
العمليه الناجحه لفصل التوام السيامي
العراقي علي وعمر ابني محمد جاسم في
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض التقطت او التقت
كاميرا العربيه بطفلين ودويهما وكذا
والداهما انهما يتمتعان بصحه جيده مقدما
شكره للسعوديه وللطخم الطبي
[موسيقى]
امورهم تمام وكل يوم تحسن اكثر الحمد لله
كنا وين وصلنا وين لله الحمد وشكرا
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه شكرا لسياده
الملك
[موسيقى]
خلال هذه الايام تختفي نجوم الجوزاء عن
الانظار لدخولها في حمره شعاع الشمس وهي
دلاله كما يقول خالد في تقويم على دخول
موسم
[موسيقى]
اخفاء وحفظ شيء الثمين عن الانظار يسمى
بالكنز والتمر الذي يوضع في مكان مخصص
والذي يسمى عندها الملولين الله يرحمهم بل
جثه اوصوبه او المنقوله يسمونه بالكنيز
ليش لانه كنز غذائي ثمين وخفاء ثريا او
الجوزه عن الانظار لدخولها في حمره شعاع
شمسي مع مغيب الشمس يسمى بالكنه هذا عندنا
واهلوا الخليج يسمونها بلخفوق فكان السماء
اخذت عقد الثريا والجوزه واخفتها عن
الانظار اذا الجوزاء يوما حلقت على
كواكبها كجمر
مو قدي
[موسيقى]
وخلال هذه الايام تختفي نجوم الجوزه عن
الانظار لدخولها في حمره شعاع شمسي مع
مغيبها وهي اماره وعلامه على بدايه فصل
الصيف والصيف له بدايه وشده ونهايه
فبدايته تسمى بالصيف وشدته تسمى بجمره
ونهايته تسمى بمرخيات القلائد والجوزه
ثلاثه نجوم وبغيابها نطلق الشتاء ثلاث
طلقات لا غابه الجوزه وبار رقيبها فلا صيف
الا صيف من العام
عايد
[موسيقى]
الختام بالعناوي
قبل دخول اتفاق في وقت اطلاق النار حيز
التنفيذ الجيش السوداني يقول ان الهدنه لا
تتضمن المسائل سياسيه
السعوديه نحو الفضاء ساعات تفصل عن عن
القرني وريان برناوي عن الانطلاق للمحطه
الدوليه
وبالتزامن مع رحله التاريخيه معارض في مدن
السعوديه للتعريف بالمهمه العلميه لرائضيه
الفضاء
اطلاقه مسمى رواق السعودي على التوسعه
الجديده للمطاف في المسجد الحرام
الوصول اولى اول رحلات الحجاج لهذا
العامله جده والمدينه 2700 حاج ومن عده
دول
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات